it's my pleasure to welcome
and the Pittsburgh and he introduced to
you Senator Barack Obama
thank you
we're through
thank you very much we have just an
extraordinary panel here today and so
I'm going to try to move as quickly as
possible to get to the main attractions
I want to thank first of all the
president of Carnegie Mellon University
thank you so much president cone for
your outstanding leadership of this
outstanding institution we also have a
couple of outstanding local leaders here
the mayor of Pittsburgh Luke Ravenstahl
where's the where did he go mr. mayor he
was here he might have slipped out
because he's got potholes to fill and
the Allegheny County Executive Dan
Onorato thank you so much both of you
for taking the time to be here in a few
minutes we'll open up this discussion
about the changes that America must make
to compete in the global economy and I'm
honored to be joined by leaders from
government and the grassroots from
business and labor from academia and the
nonprofit sector because for America to
succeed we'll have to join together to
harness the energy and the ingenuity of
the American people and this morning I'd
like to talk about how we're going to do
just that for the last three weeks I've
been traveling around the country
talking about how we can change our
economy so that it works for the
American people and I've also been
listening
I met with parents in Wisconsin who
struggled to afford groceries to let
their family eat decently or the gas
that takes them to and from work I've
talked to a man in Missouri who whose
wife works two jobs and as arthritis
costs $1,500 a week to treat I've heard
from a student in Minnesota was done
everything that's been asked of her but
worries that she won't be able to take
her final tests because she's maxed out
on her student loans stories like this
can be found all across the country the
because far too many Americans are
working hard and doing their part but
still can't keep pace it's time for us
to recognize that these individual
stories connect to a larger American
story all of us have a stake in our
common prosperity when people are
struggling on Main Street that pain
trickles up to Wall Street and just as
we have to provide relief to Americans
who are struggling we also have to
recognize that we're failing to put
ourselves in a position to compete
effectively in the global economy our
country faces challenges to our
leadership in this young century our
children will grow up facing competition
from their counterparts in Beijing and
Bangalore if we don't change course
there's no guarantee that the American
Dream will be there for my daughters or
your sons as it was there for us America
risks falling behind if we remain
dependent on oil from dictators will
endanger our security in parallel our
planet pay more at the pump and sit on
the sidelines while the jobs of the
future are created abroad if we can't
give every child in America the chance
to get a world-class education will
cripple their ability to make a living
in a knowledge-based economy and watch
China and India move ahead in the race
for the 21st century if we can't control
skyrocketing health care costs we'll
confront a mounting moral crisis in a
major anchor on the ability of American
business to compete and if we don't
rebuild our crumbling roads bridges and
electrical grids
we'll see our standard of living suffer
while we leave our communities less safe
from terror and natural disaster if we
don't invest and encourage innovation we
could seed America's historic role as
the engine of growth in progress and
discovery for the entire world these
challenges are real how we deal with
them will shape the prosperity of every
single American and the future of
America's leadership in the 21st century
now it falls to us to look at these
problems and see the possibilities
embedded within them it falls to us to
do what generations of Americans have
done before and remake the world as it
should be my opponent in this campaign
has served this country with honor and I
look forward to debating him on these
issues because we have a very different
view of the choices that America needs
to make he is supported and would
continue an agenda that I believe has
failed to keep pace with the challenges
of 21st century I'm convinced that we
must move in a new direction if we have
the courage to commit to change the
American people cannot just sees but
shape the opportunities of the global
economy
together we can author our own story
together we can pursue a 21st century
leadership agenda that's focused on five
areas energy education health care
infrastructure and innovation success
will not come from Washington alone it
must come from the dynamism and
determination and ingenuity of the
American people through partnerships of
states and cities the public in the
private sector and through the active
involvement of the American people but
we also know that for our country to
succeed Washington has to change because
at moments of great economic
transformation government must serve as
the catalyst for change to leverage all
sectors of American society that are
represented here today this can be the
moment when we make a truly national
effort to end our addiction to or just
as Roosevelt invested in arsenal of
democracy and Kennedy took us to the
moon we can be the generation that
achieves energy security grows our
economy and saves our planet American
presidents have been calling for this
kind of effort since Nixon but now is
the time to act we could have made that
choice in 2000 but instead we got secret
task forces and greater energy
dependence and we've watched as
countries like Brazil and Germany have
created hundreds of thousands of jobs in
the energy sector we failed to act and
we've fallen behind and that's why I've
proposed investing 150 billion dollars
in a green energy sector to
five million new jobs good jobs that
can't be outsourced but this must merely
be a spark for American industry and
innovators to develop alternatives to
oil and gas to create a new energy
economy if we do this the great assembly
line manufacturers the 20th century can
turn out cars that run on renewable
energy the dictators who hold ha who
hold our security hostage will see their
leverage disappear along with their
revenue the oceans will no longer rise
our planet will be preserved and that's
what we must do as a centerpiece of our
competitiveness strategy as a nation
this can also
this could also be a moment when we make
a historic commitment to education
because we can't be satisfied until
every child in America and I mean every
child has the same chance to get a
world-class education that we want for
our children we need to commit 10
billion dollars to give every child
access to early quality childhood
education but we also need but we also
need a 50-state strategy that reaches
down to the grassroots to have
successful schools we need to recruit an
army of new teachers and provide them
with better pay and more support
just as we develop new curricula and
renewed accountability to lift up our
children we need a national commitment
but we also need parents to get up off
the couch turn off the TV and to read to
their children
to educate the best workforce in the
world a college education should be the
birthright of every American but we also
have to ask our young people to invest
in America through service and we need
to work with our community colleges to
provide new skills and lifelong learning
that's what we must do to extend the
American dream this can be the moment
when we finally come together to make
health care affordable and accessible
for every single American and lower
costs for all American families here in
Pittsburgh we've seen the advances that
can be made when we see opportunities
embedded in providing health care we can
create a future where medical records
are electronic enhancing care and
lowering costs we can invest in new
cures and put a new emphasis on
prevention so that we have a healthier
and more productive population we can
forge new alliances between business and
labor to ensure that workers are covered
and the corporations are no longer
saddled with rising costs that's how
we're going to care for our people and
help the American corporation compete
this can be the moment when we make a
generational commitment to rebuild our
infrastructure that's what Teddy
Roosevelt did when he brought together
leaders from the public and private
sector to plan for 20th century
infrastructure and that's what we must
do here in the 21st century
Washington concede this effort and
that's why I've proposed putting 60
billion dollars into a national
infrastructure reinvestment bank to
rebuild our roads and bridges our rails
and ports this must leverage the kind of
private investment that can create
millions of jobs and remake our
communities years from now we could
drive on new roads depend on safe
bridges and stronger levees and connect
our cities with high-speed rail we can
big begin the investment in a smart
electrical grid to power electric cars
and transmit clean energy across the
country and we can achieve the simple
goal of making sure that every American
has access to high-speed broadband no
matter how much money you have or where
you come from you should have access to
this technology and that's what we have
to do to make sure that America runs on
a strong fair and efficient foundation
and this can be the moment when we
invest in the science and innovation
that will help shape our future because
in a technology driven economy America
must always stay on the cutting edge
that means reversing a trend that we
devote a smaller and smaller share of
our natural resources to research and
development an innovation agenda must
commit to funding basic research and
making the R&D Tax Credit permanent it
must also exempt startups from capital
gains taxes and remove bureaucratic
barriers to entrepreneurs for instance
by making our patent process more
efficient and reliable we need the
discoveries of tomorrow to be made in
our labs and universities and Pitt and
Carnegie Mellon we need two success
stories of tomorrow the next Google or
the next Microsoft to take place here in
the United States now this agenda
this is Jenna's ambitious it will take
resources in the wake of policies that
have run up our debt but the answer to
our fiscal problems is not to
shortchange investments in our ability
to compete investments that are vital to
long-term growth to stop mortgaging our
children's future we need to eliminate
waste in existing programs we need to
responsibly end the war in Iraq generate
revenue by charging polluters for their
emissions and put an end to corporate
loopholes and tax cuts that are not
making America more productive we can
have
we can have a smarter government that
pays its way while investing in the
country's future
that's how Washington must change to
become a catalyst for growth because in
cities and towns across America I know
that the American people are ready to
rise to the challenge of a new moment
they just haven't been asked it's time
for that change because there's nothing
that Americans cannot accomplish when
they are working together you know for
250 years
that's what's been done here in
Pittsburgh this is where US Steel became
the first billion-dollar corporation and
turned out more steel at the dawn of the
Cold War than the entire Soviet Union
and just as that output built our cities
and laid down the rails that connected
them the work that created that wealth
was the foundation of a middle class
where each generation opportunities
could extend a little further and each
individual's story could advance the
larger American story many of those
steel mills are gone but this American
city has found new opportunities through
health and IT through finance and
universities now we must connect that
local innovation and ingenuity to a
national strategy the American story is
never static but as we move from one
chapter to the next we must always
remember that our national greatness is
advanced when we act on our fundamental
goodness America succeeds when the
playing field is level and open and
people don't fall behind when government
is not an obstacle but a catalyst for
shared prosperity when we come together
to find new ways to expand the horizon
of opportunity for each and every
American and with your help that's the
kind of America that I want to build
this president the United States all
right thank you
you